(617) 830-4750 is the number. Let's go to
our caller from the nine seven eight area
code. Who's calling today from nine, seven,
eight.
Okay.
Hello. This is Steve.
Hey Steve. What's going on?
Okay.
Hey, how are you doing? Um, so, uh, I'm a
mass resident. Um, I guess I consider myself
more of a libertarian than anything else.
Um, and kind of being a libertarian, I think
my general nature has always been to kind
of be a person that's in the middle or tries
to see things from the middle and I can typically
appreciate both points of view, so forth and
so on. And one of the things that I'm struggling
with in general is this polarization towards
poverty and the fact that we seem to be in
this pattern where once one party takes office
or takes, seemingly takes control of things,
they reign supreme and they basically steamroll
over the other party completely at the expense
of it. And of course there's always some sort
of moral or other justification for doing
so.
Okay. So hold on. That's a good, that's explore
whether that's, if we're going to discuss
that we should explore whether that's the
case. What's an example of how, for example,
the Obama Administration steamrolled Republicans
and did stuff.
Alright. So I'm a person, that's my, my, my
memory with things in general, just day to
day life things honestly is just like terrible.
So I mean, when I have to recall something,
I mean, I can't even remember my kids' birthdays
for crying out loud. So it's very difficult
for me to just do that kind of stuff in general.
Okay, fair. So I guess what I was trying to
get to is I simply don't think that it happens
the way you're saying it happens. So let me
give you the, the Obama example. President
Obama became president of the United States
in 2008. He was inaugurated in 2009. He had
the house and Senate for those first two years
until the tea party surge, um, took, took
over control of, uh, I guess it was just the
house in 2010, 2010. Um, what was he able
to do? It's like, okay, he got Obamacare passed,
which was a center right idea from a conservative
think tank from the 90s which gave tens of
millions of new customers to for-profit insurance
companies. We had sandy hook and hold on.
Yes. And message and Romneycare. We had sandy
hook and like 90% consensus in the u s that
we need 100% universal background checks.
He still wasn't able to get it done. So I
just re he was, he, he had a supreme court
pick which Republicans just said, yeah, we're
not even going to hold confirmation hearing.
So I don't see any steam rolling that the
Po that the president in power was able to
even do.
Okay. So, so certainly when, certainly there
are interesting dynamics when when you have
like a, like a congress and the executive
branch that are, that are aligned and you
would think then that they would just simply
get their way into everything. Well, there's,
there's a funny dynamic that seems to happen
where the parties all of a sudden become aware
of that and that opens the door for them to
be, you know, more polarizing towards things
that are going on, let's say in their own
state, their own constituents and stuff. And
that kind of infighting prevents additional
things from potentially happening.
But Steve, isn't that, isn't that the exact
opposite? Aren't you conceding that it's actually
the opposite. You said your concern is a party
gets a party, wins the White House, and then
they steamroll everybody in the other party.
I kind of gave a counter example saying, well,
it didn't happen under Obama, and you're saying,
oh, right. Yeah. Because when one party is
in power, they start in fighting and they
still actually don't really get that much
done. That's kind of the opposite of your
initial argument, isn't it? Which I'm glad
that we're figuring out where I'm not criticizing
you. I'm just saying it seems that you're
agreeing with me that it doesn't quite happen
the way you suggested.
Well, I think, I think to some extent that's,
that's true. And I, and I'm willing, I'm certainly
willing to concede that. But, so I think that
the thing with, with steam rolling, and here's
kind of what I mean, like this, this, this
notion of, you know, both, you know, branches,
kind of the, they have these committees and
they go off and they, they, they work on,
you know, creating some sort of bill that
they hope becomes a law. And they do it by
themselves. They're in these, their own little
echo chambers, whether it's, uh, you know,
democratic, whether it's Republican and whatever.
And they come out knowing full well that the
OPP that the other side is going to have supreme
opposition to it. And then try to push that
through. I come from a base where I like collaboration
and compromise. So for example, and you know,
we have things with, you know, voter id.
We have things with, you know, guns and gun
controls and stuff. An example of a collaboration
in my point of view, in other words, we're
concussions, we're gonna genuinely consider
the other party's point of view, their needs.
So forth and so on. Might be, you know what?
Why don't we try to pass things like, like
voter id, but why don't we also try to pass
things like a gun reform where we have, you
know, the extensive background checks where
we make sure that people are truly registered
and licensed and they know all about weapons
safety and stuff.
I'll tell you why Steve, because that's exactly
how we end up in these situations where you
have a bill about voter id where the opposition
party says let's stuff some things about gun
control in there, and then the other party
says, hey, that doesn't really have anything
to do with what we're doing. And the other
party says, well, if you don't pass my gun
control thing, I'm not going to it. We've
seen that that already is what they try to
do and it just doesn't really work that well.
It creates a different type of a of gridlock.
I appreciate what you're saying. I am always,
you know, I would make, I would, I would suggest
people reexamined the EIT if they see themselves
as the sort of enlightened centrists who could
make everybody come together. I would read
a little bit of the history of American politics
over the last 40 years to realize it's not
a, it's not quite so simple. I got to move
on, but I appreciate the phone call, Steve.
Sure. Thank you.
All right. Take care.